okay
today i have with me one of the leading
members of the world in uh international
mafia of polyglots good lord who meet
yeah who meet from time to time and
put out videos and produce various
things for language learning and a
fellow that i respect tremendously for
his language skills and his
entrepreneurship around language
learning ollie richards
who joins us from somewhere in england i
believe yes lockdown in london
coming to you lockdown in london okay
and uh the other day i saw you had put
out a new series of books
or a book in your series of readers i
can't remember which language tell us a
little bit about you and about your um
graded readers that you've been and and
the other uh
yeah okay yeah yeah what are you up to
tell us dude a lot of my uh you know
viewers will know you but bring us up
today well thanks for the uh that's the
intro i see if i can live up to that so
yeah my name is ollie richard and i um i
blog at a website called i will teach
you a language.com and that's where i
kind of started this whole journey
and uh over the years i've kind of
shifted into teaching languages and
creating books and courses to teach
people and i use a i have an approach
that centers around stories i call this
method story learning
that's how i'm kind of branding it these
days
and so
to help people do that i create books
and courses which are all based all have
a story at the heart of it so we're
giving people
um lots of nice fun uh input at good
level along with different kinds of
instruction to help them to help them
learn um and i've yes i've released um a
series of grady readers with teach
yourself which i'm sure
some of you guys are getting
sure yes absolutely i've got lots of new
languages in there got turkish and
things like that oh turkish i'm going to
get turkey
swedish
teach yourself are great because they
are all for
like creating stuff in less common
languages so we're currently working on
welsh how about that
japanese and um yeah so i um what i've
been up to is i
i mean my i see my career a bit
differently these days
i used to just spend all my time
learning languages now i
don't do so much of that in recent years
i haven't been doing so much of that in
recent years i'm
i'm kind of getting becoming more
interested in how i can kind of create
stuff to help other people learn and
that's um pretty much what i'm focusing
on these days
well you know this is the problem i am
have been working on my persian and
arabic
but it's hard to find the time yeah
because uh we're doing these other
things now and then we can't find enough
time to to work on languages but i do
enjoy exploring new languages and i hope
you come up with some graded readers in
turkey well turkish i put on the back
burner because i want to get better at
reading in the arabic script so i'm
focusing in on persian and arabic but
there is a lack of content in those
languages a lack of content in the sort
of intermediate level which is kind of
what you're focusing on you know we do
your beginner book and then the next
thing you go to is a podcast which i
have transcribed but those are very
difficult for me and so to have
something in the middle is is very very
good uh and it's also it's interesting
it's interesting to think that
i mean someone with your level of
experience says you know to jump up to
that that kind of native level is very
very difficult for you for someone who's
doing it for the first time it's nigh on
impossible because they just don't have
that limp to experience that belief that
it's actually possible so you know
that's why i think the stuff that that
i'm doing and the stuff that you guys do
at link is is so important because it
just kind of provides that bridge from
your beginner's textbook to more
interesting content
one thing you said there was i think
really interesting first of all that
they haven't done it before so they
don't have the experience obviously but
they don't believe they can do it
and i think that's a big part of why
experienced language learners like we
are we may not be very good but we're
experienced you know
uh we know we're going to get there
we're going to get somewhere and and
whenever we get to we're happy with it
we never question ourselves but i think
a lot of you know your typical person
that goes to the library and studies
spanish and has been doing it for 10
years and has never gotten anywhere
basically they're convinced they never
will
they will never get fluent they'll get a
little better at ordering things in a
restaurant but they have a very low
level it seems of ambition and they have
no confidence yeah and that but that is
a very i mean
it's an extremely um
important part of the psyche of the
language learner you know because it's
and i think people express it in
different ways and it's not always
you know if you ask them if you kind of
confronted them with that and said look
you don't you don't believe you can do
this can you they they're i'm not sure
how they react to that they'd probably
think no i don't know i can but i do
think for a lot of people there is this
kind of you know just it's like what if
i fail
you know what if i can't well and that
is there lingering in the back of the
mind
sure and it's just simply the fact that
they've never done it so
you know how can you you know they have
trouble visualizing themselves as
someone speaking another language
fluently they've never done it that's
understandable and that's the vast
majority of language learners and that's
why i think your series is so good one
thing i did for example in persian
which i would like to see by the way
here's a suggestion to you
i'm not a big fan of stories
i like history
so i had i found this uh
young lady in
iran
who creates content for me in persian
and one of the things she did she
created 26 episodes of the history of
iran
in very simple language read slowly
and
every episode is about five six minutes
long and then it's followed by five six
minutes of these circling questions
so you know
whatever persia went to war with greece
did persia go to war with turkey no
persia went to war with greece so you
have these circling questions where the
answer is more or less given you don't
have to try to remember what was in the
lesson you just have to hear the
statement hear the question and hear the
answer and so that reinforces some of
the vocabulary and so the more
vocabulary you have a better grasp on
when you listen to the main episode
again you'll understand a little bit
more so and i remember when i was
learning chinese we had a book called 20
lectures on chinese culture which was at
a thousand character level so
i know you like stories and i like
stories but for those of us who like
nonfiction
if you could ever develop a series honey
you should say that uh we've actually
got a few things in development right
now one is um
and
the
thing i like about your persian example
is it's specific to persian
and from a kind of production point of
view that kind of thing is actually it's
fantastic but it's a bit limiting
because
um
you know you're going to make unique
resources for each language and of the
the scalability of what you lose right
right so that's that's the that's the
particular challenge but um i'm also
like when i actually spend time learning
myself i also i'm also partial to
non-fiction i like um like history like
biographies i like business books and
things like that so we're actually
developing at the moment um
quite an exciting series which is the
history of world war ii
in
simple spanish french german and england
okay and then and we're also doing um
uh climate change in simple
working our working
through different um different different
like
hot topics if you like
that's an excellent excellent and and
that has the advantage too that those
are subjects that are familiar to people
and so if you're learning a language and
the subject matter is familiar to you
already you have an advantage yeah for
sure yeah there's there's that there's
also the kind of practical point that if
we if we create a you know content like
that in spanish it can also it can
fairly easily be oh sure no i was lucky
i understand that but i'm saying from
the point of view of the learner
uh that's very good because whatever's
familiar is is easier yeah exactly i
always get mad at these
language courses which start out with
the most exotic aspects of the local
culture so you're going to learn korean
and they give you three or four
different ways of saying my sister
you know festivals and all kinds of
stuff that you have no relationship to
at all so it adds to the difficulty it
doesn't
make it easier yeah i love the example
of the persian um you know the history
of history of persian culture though
that because because that's um you know
although it might be unfamiliar to
someone who's just learning the language
at the start it is also the
often the reason that you're learning
the language you know so to be able to
do a deep dive
in that in that kind of topic area is is
extremely useful
yeah we don't really get into the sort
of
persian festivals or stuff like that
although she does have a series where
she talks about different things persian
but in the history i mean in a sense
it's familiar you you hear about the
greek persian wars from the persian
perspective you read about you know
persian
going into india and stuff so you are
dealing with world history
and not sort of very specific cultural
things but it's good she's very good
she's got a clear voice and it's it's
really good i'd love to have that in
other languages
uh
many of the languages that i'm learning
these days are not ones that you're
producing books for although i see
turkish so that's good
yeah yeah it's i mean it's always this
balance isn't it between you know what's
uh what what
because ultimately well because this
this stuff costs a lot of money to make
right so you've got to be able to yeah
recover your costs and um you know i
we're kind of dipping our toes in the
water with different languages for sure
um but it kind of it has to be a gradual
thing because otherwise you know i'd
love to make all the stuff in the world
for persian but then if little things
like little things like amazon kindle
don't support permission
um yeah i'm i'm i'm i'm working on it
but i'm it's gonna be some time coming
all right so let me ask you now we've
been in this sort of language learning
teaching polyglot
uh environment for quite a few years and
of course we were learning languages
long before the internet and and mp3 at
least i was i don't know maybe you were
yeah
so so what what do you think have been
the major changes
uh
and what do you think are the things
that are changing now and where is that
going to take us as far as language
learning last few years it seems that
everything's going to come on like
there's been some pretty seismic shifts
i think there's a few a few different
ways to
to look at it i mean i think the big the
big shift with the internet on the whole
is just the availability of content you
know the fact that you can just um
you know you can just access the daily
newspaper from any given country
from anywhere in anywhere in the world
um so so
that from a language learning
perspective i think is the most
most important change you know that plus
video chat obviously is a huge thing um
but i think it's interesting how that
hasn't necessarily made things easier or
better um i
um i guess that's a different different
different topic but i mean certainly the
availability of resources and the access
to video chat is the big thing
um right the of course the apps and
things like that have been exploding
there are all kinds of new technology um
out there i
from my perspective 99 of which is
effectively useless or adds nothing to
the um to the experience although there
are some
some particular
you know um
particular tech resources that have been
developed by language learners that that
are genuinely helpful like i can't link
as
among the outliers with that
um and then um and then you've also but
the one of the interesting things i'm
seeing now is that there's a there's a
there's a
group of people who are um
coming up and they're most visible on
youtube because you know youtube
seems to have kind of replaced
everything as the kind of go-to content
place you know i i always thought i
started off through blogging you know
that's that that's that's what i did um
and now kind of you know youtube is is
so big and so invisible i i'm i'm
fascinated by this um kind of new
generation of people who are doing
who are learning languages documenting
what they're doing but also kind of
marrying that up with all the latest
technology you know and i see people
like like uh like harry
sommer and uh he ken uh
um matt
from matt vs japan these guys are all
very young
and they're all they're all
they're really embracing new technology
i saw you on the on vr chat the other
day with harry which was which was
fantastic um but they're also kind of
i feel like the thing that one of the
things that that sets these guys apart
from
and girls apart from
from certainly how i feel they're kind
of digital natives in a way that i'm not
so
i i i kind of had to learn this stuff
i'm the same as same as you i imagine
uh you know i had to kind of learn the
internet i had to learn youtube and
learn learn blogging and stuff whereas
these guys have actually kind of grown
up with it and they they're so adept
with the different platforms that are
out there
that i think that
seems to me to be the
the genesis of something
of a real kind of a really big change i
don't know what that change is going to
be but
the fact that they've grown up with this
technology um
is
is is important i think right from all
of this you know
i don't see any evidence that people are
only better at languages or language
learning than they used to be um right
you know
and i remember talking to luca about
this
uh a few years back the fact that
we both sort of felt that one of the one
of our big advantages we felt was that
we remember what language learning used
to be like before the internet
we remember what it used to be like to
go to in my case the european bookshop
in soho in central london and to go down
to the
the you know the french section and
there would be like
two or three french books to choose from
and that's your lot
you know so you take one or two and
that's that's all you've got and then
you want to learn french you better use
these books
and so you just go through them cover
together and you focus and you
concentrate and um
and then the day that you find another
book in the library it's like you found
a gem and you just you really you know
take it home and you focus
and i think that the the big
my big question mark over over the kind
of growth of technology smartphones in
particular
is that
i
just see people
distracted to a level which is so
um
which makes language learning so
difficult because language learning for
me is all about focus and depth and the
ability to concentrate on things
and i that's
the precise thing that for me
smartphones and social media and things
are taking away from people and so i
just wonder you know people are growing
up with this
how
how do they never how do they navigate
the the the skills of
these basic study skills or focus on
concentration i don't know the answer to
that um but that's um those are some of
the big topics that i think
i've seen
yeah that's very interesting and
certainly i can relate to when i was
learning chinese in hong kong going to
the bookstore i remember the story
yeah and and finding readers like in
those days there were no online
dictionaries so and i certainly didn't
want to go through a chinese dictionary
to look up every word so where they were
readers and there were so many readers
you know history chinese politics
whatever
and literature and they would have these
word lists so if i found a new reader
with a new word list i was delighted i'd
go home and work on it i did the same in
japanese
uh so
nowadays you don't really need to do
that because you can grab anything and
look up the word online
uh
so i mean to me that's an improvement it
you have to agree though at least it's
my impression that for everyone that
goes into a bookstore to pick up a book
on spanish or french
maybe a lot of them leave without buying
a book
some of them buy the book take it home
and never open it
or they open the book and do five
chapters never get any further so i'm
not convinced that those people then
were
more successful than people now
i do agree that i mean i'm on my ipad
and i'm going through my uh whatever it
is in persian and arabic and every 20
minutes or so i check my twitter feed so
i'm distracted yeah
i happen to enjoy following events on
twitter but uh that's a negative like
it's nothing is a hundred percent
better you always gain something and
lose something however the fact that i
can have my phone if i go and i'm
waiting in line somewhere and i can be
going through my lesson in persian
on link you know on my iphone or if i if
i'm standing i'll be doing that or if
i'm driving i'll be listening
i have my language with me all the time
so
and if i look at um
you know i find that you know learning
languages like arabic and persian and
greek i learned it up in no time and i
don't think i would have done that
you know 50 years ago i mean my
situation with chinese was i was paid by
the canadian government to be a language
student so i was full-time seven hours a
day learning chinese to now i have an
hour or two a day mixed in with other
activities i think i'm pretty efficient
uh
taking advantage and and i agree with
you with youtube uh and and i i don't
even take advantage of it because
there's no persian like i'm learning
persian and arabic the worst languages
like i haven't found any persian like we
can import movies from youtube into link
as lessons the audio the video and the
text is there
but
there i haven't come across any standard
arabic movies right they all
are spoken in a dialect of some kind
maybe with arabic uh subtitles and
similarly with persian so and maybe i
just haven't found them so uh no i i i i
i agree with you in theory and that
there are people have trouble focusing
and and there are distractions but i
think the the benefits
outweigh the disadvantages well that's
the thing i mean it depends on the
perspective of the person right so i
mean i you know absolutely i'm kind of
looking looking at this through my
perspective of having kind of seen this
this all of this stuff develop i mean
you know you're in your case you you're
able to
bring
these memories of
different ways of language learning
into this new world and you're able to
that is
inevitably going to inform how you go
about stuff
um now and right and
but you know ultimately it is going to
be a case of
i mean you know people still have to
study they still got to still go to
college they have to figure out how to
pass exams and things like that so yeah
i mean when at the end of the day
you've got the resources that are
available and it's it's down to you how
you how you use them and it's it's it's
the extent of which you're able to use
these resources in in a smart way that's
going to determine um
your your
your your success
i guess i just i i
i think there's a big um
tendency which is probably
well it's all marketing isn't it but
there's a big tendency with the
evolution of technology to make to
portray things as being quick and easy
right and i guess it was like it was
ever that's right i mean you always had
the you know um
textbooks which you know the old uh you
know self-study text but you know
become fluent in
in spanish by the time you finish this
text which obviously is obviously
nonsense
so it was always that that way but i
mean i think particularly with the
development of language apps and things
like that there is this tendency to
let's press these buttons for five
minutes a day and you'll be uh and
you'll be off to the races um which is
you know again
but even but even assimil which has
almost a cult following amongst the sort
of sophisticated language learners they
say you'll be at b2 when you finish this
book
you know which is of course not the case
because you need so much content so much
listening and reading so one little book
is not going to get you to b2 but they
say that right there on the little
corner yeah
i'm sure we went back and found the unit
you know the the
the earliest examples of uh of language
textbooks it would be the same kind of
thing
master the language you finish this
you'll be able to speak with confidence
you're able to understand and that's
simply not true and um so it still comes
back to your motivation right what's
going on
what yeah it keeps you
you know you're talking about you've
been learning persian arabic what
what is it that
is it purely the love of the is it the
is it is it the love of the process is
it the exploration of culture what is it
that motivates you to to keep adding
these news
it's fun uh to enjoy the you enjoy the
i enjoy discovering those cultures so
you know i have a lot of um
you know romance languages asians a lot
you know all in my asian languages
slavic languages so i started and then i
was going to visit crete so i thought i
can't be i can't go to greece if i can't
speak the language so work on greek uh
now i'm in the middle east
and
it's fascinating so
i'm learning about persian so then i buy
a book
in fact my son gave me a book called the
persian
period in indian history i hadn't
realized the tremendous influence that
persia had on india for example
i read a book about the indian ocean and
the context between oman and the african
coast and india and the portuguese and i
to me i like history and and when you
explore it through the language you get
a much better sense the people come
alive even the little bit that i did in
turkish and then i i watched my wife is
walking and watching a turkish series on
netflix or we saw it
it just brings those people alive
otherwise you end up with these very
sort of uh
limited uh
perspectives on
arabic world or persia
just it's just with another language
like persian how long does it take you
before you're able to kind of
comfortably
read and extract meaning from it from a
history textbook like that because
that's that's that's well i don't
know i can't read a history textbook
okay i can read simplified history where
i have can look up words and then i
listen to it like so everything i do i
listen and read i use link i learn
exclusively on link uh learning the
arabic script which is the same as the
persian script takes a long time even if
you you know you start out and it's just
a bunch of squigglies
it was a
quite intimidating actually but then
you don't get worse you only get better
so you have to stay with it stay with it
now i read with difficulty and that's
one of the reasons why i dropped turkish
because i want to totally focus on
getting better and better and better at
reading that script it takes time but i
enjoy it
so so you're in yeah because you're
enjoying the process but you're building
towards the promise of being able to
actually learn
and
yeah and i have no no i'll be out of for
quite a while and and i may somehow oh
we haven't heard you speak arabic in a
while and
whatever i might speak at some point but
right now i'm just gradually getting
better i have
a
uh
person who provides transcripts
from tunisia i say you just go to this
al jazeera
podcast
called lava
and just pick out whatever you want send
me two a week she sends me two
transcribed podcasts and i go through
them and similarly with persian
um
you know sahara sends me two transcripts
a week from
radio for europe actually fardo
and that's my schedule i gotta get
through these things
and uh i understand more and more of
them just by listening but of course i
still only whatever twenty thirty
percent so then i have to go through the
transcripts and and uh
read them on link and i'll see there's
lots of white words now there's more and
more uh more and more white words
actually lots of yellow words fewer and
fewer blue words and so i'm i'm slowly
getting better and there will come a
point where
you know i'll be comfortable just
grabbing that podcast and and listening
to it and i'll understand eighty percent
of it yeah well maybe it used to be yeah
you need to write steve's uh steve's
history of persia then and um you know
the content that you own which can then
be become the new uh you know
the person yeah there's as you say
there's not a mark there's not a big
market for that
and uh we don't get text-to-speech for
persian for some strange reason we have
it for arabic i find text-to-speech very
helpful especially with that writing
system so there's problems
um but
it would be great like if we get people
creating content in their own language
and talk about their history of where
they live i found a guy in the sudan who
started talking about sudan and gave us
four or five
tremendous things about life in sudan he
went to buy stuff on the dusty roads and
waiting in line and
it was just great stuff
uh but then he stopped doing it the
trouble is you can't rely on on
volunteers i end up i pay people i pay
the person in iran i pay the person in
uh yeah yeah tunisia you gotta pay and
so i mean i happen to be in a position
where i can i can do that i can
i can share the radio free europe stuff
i looked up their turns of use and
conform to their thing i'd love to be
able to share the al jazeera stuff but
they don't let you i sent them an email
can we share this transcript in our
library with our learners of course you
never get an answer
so so anyway yes okay i can't use it so
you've been learning arabic for a few
years now so i mean have you yeah i mean
i i certainly found like during my time
in the middle east that
the arab world for me is just like
endless fascination
um
i i
for years now been wanting to to just re
read a lot a lot more than i that than
i've been able to but it's just one of
these cultures where like the more time
you spend with it the more the more the
more you find the more you discover
yeah and it's i mean that's true with
everything i mean persia is the same way
turkey but it's very interesting you
know the the middle east and africa the
middle east yeah
yeah
yeah yeah and the more the more time i
spent with with with that i think maybe
for me because i spent time living in
qatar in egypt as well so that kind of i
feel like i have some kind of connection
to that
you know
you've got a big advantage even though
it's uh it's so different from
from you know
from where i grew up and everything but
it has it has it's it's it has a magic
and charm to it which i i find instantly
fascinating and i find myself
gravitating to you know tv programs and
documentaries about the middle east more
and more and more even though i spent
more time away from it um yeah so it's
it's fantastic have you been um
how has arabic
uh
how has arabic
influenced your
i was going to say world view but i'm
sure you already knew a lot about
that part of the world before you
started learning arabic but how was it
how has it changed things for you
spending time with that well i just have
a better sense i've been to morocco and
then we visited jordan petra period
um
you know i just have a better sense of
that world i i've discovered that uh
sort of egyptian arabic and levantine
arabic are closer to each other than
they are to fusa
it seems to me that's my impression uh
it just entered arabic on the other
standard arabic pops up all the time so
if you'll be watching a
netflix series uh in egyptian or say 11
from lebanon and there'll be something
on tv in the background and they're
speaking standard arabic or i we were
watching the syrian series or lebanese
rather and they were part of it they
were rehearsing for a play
in fact it was the dollhouse by ibsen
for whatever reason you know talk about
different cultures right so here you are
in lebanon and they're rehearsing for
this
play written by a norwegian but they're
speaking standard arabic in the play
so it what's fascinating to me is the
extent to which standard arabic is alive
i found even in morocco i found people
who would speak to me in standard arabic
a lady running a restaurant a taxi
driver
so
uh it
it's just fun to discover i'm glad the
strategy i we do have at link now we
have the many stories in egyptian arabic
and in levantine arabic and i've
listened to them i understand them but
i'm staying with standard arabic because
most of the history and the political
stuff that i like to listen to is in
standard arabic yeah i mean it's one of
those cases of justice yeah we're
knowing standard arabic it does it's
funny because it's like not for speaking
it's not particularly handy but then if
what you actually want to spend your
time doing is is reading well it's the
only choice
right
but but i think going forward you know
the fact that there are so many
resources the fact that to me the
perspective is that
it used to be that the teacher knows the
language you don't know it the teacher
gives you the language that's gone
because i can find the language anywhere
i can find explanations i can find
content
everywhere
so the teacher is now more of a guide
more of someone who encourages you
and and i think the teachers have to get
better at helping people navigate all of
the resources that are available the
first of all to stimulate them i had a
teacher who stimulated me when i was 17
years old
the teacher is the person who gets you
going
because motivation is is so important
but it's not the expert on you know
arabic grammar i don't need an expert on
arabic grammar i'm not interested
uh
seven types of verbs or something you
open these books and they got this
ridiculous stuff like i
i don't need seven types of verbs
um so i think that's so then so going
forward i think it's a matter of of uh
getting you started
and then sort of some graded reading
material to bring you up to the next
level and then helping you
take advantage of netflix and youtube
and books and stuff like that
but as you say the danger when people
are on their iphone or their ipad is
that they're
very easily distracted
so i don't know what uh what can be done
yeah and i guess yeah i mean i
mostly makes you think about teacher
education in general and how much
teachers really think about that there
is always this dynamic between teachers
and teacher and student where
and also this is guided by student
expectations students expect to be to be
taught you know in a traditional way but
then you know it's very it's very
easy for
for teachers to kind of slip into this
trap of justifying their hourly fee by
actually having presented a certain
quantity of information
right so
i know some of the more kind of
enlightened teacher training um courses
around the world do do do sort of um you
know stress the importance of learner
autonomy it's kind of buzzword
and uh you know motivating your your
learners but it's always something of an
afterthought you know whereas i
completely agree with you it really
should be the the 80 the 80 20 of the
whole exercise you know how can you how
can you
how can you guide your students towards
finding material that's going to
interest them and you know light a spark
and get them spending time with the
language if you can do that you've yeah
and the internet you know and you bring
it back to the to the topic like
it's never been easier
um but you do know he's never been do
you need someone to guide you to look
for that stuff because it's not
immediately obvious for the student that
that's what they should you know that's
a
a sensible path forward
right but i think what's good too is
that there are entrepreneurs
like you like me
and like the people who created the
duolingo and whatever and some of the
stuff is useful some isn't
some people like
certain things and
other things i should say that we do
have some of ollie's material at link
i think what you're doing is very useful
thank you uh
i think that uh you know uh graded
material particularly with a script now
you're doing spanish french and some of
the more traditional aren't you but you
have chinese right now arabic steve have
you seen the arabic book we have arabic
oh
go
where have you been where have you been
i gotta get this oh listen okay arabic
short stories
i will uh where do i buy it
i find finding stores everywhere
all right i'm gonna to amazon basically
right now okay i will get it i will get
it and that's in standard arabic it is
yeah origin yeah okay
so i think that's what's important
and
by the way it's the way it should be
yeah well of course
yeah but you've got a lot of textbooks
that are not you know left to right and
and the other thing about books is
getting back to our being distracted i
mean having a book in your hand is nice
and i like i like i wish for some of the
material we had at link that we also had
a book because
it's always good to cover the same
material using different sources it's
also good to cover the same material
using different uh technologies like a
book versus doing it on the ipad so i am
going to get your arabic thing and
follow up on the turkish so we've had a
bit of a random ramble here
good uh we didn't know what we were
going to quite talk about
but um yeah any final thoughts to my
viewers about language learning
keep listening to steve and you'll be
all right
ah jeez and i'll see keep listening to
ollie and you'll be all right
okay thank you very much
okay be careful be safe
[Music]
you